[Music]
what's going on guys I'm coming to you
today in a brand new sweater it's cold
outside I like it
leave me alone every once in a while I
like to do what I call a passion video
and to me what that is is it's a video
that I don't necessarily have to make
like I do movie reviews each week but
every once in a while I've come up with
a video or I just feel like there's
something I have to talk about like it's
a topic that must be discussed because
it's been on my mind and it's something
that I think a lot of other gamers are
concerned about and that is the state of
the current generation of consoles now
obviously they're very new Xbox one just
came out a couple days ago ps4 just came
out the other week these are two systems
that have not been around for a long
time at all however there are a lot of
launch issues and because of that
there's kind of this discussion that's
been brought up amongst a lot of gamers
about the way systems are made nowadays
the way system launches are handled the
type of games that are released and the
way that games and systems are made in
general compared to the way they used to
be made and whether or not all these
technological advances are actually
benefiting us as gamers now before you
get ready to type that I'm a retro gamer
and I don't like new games I love new
games in fact I'm very much eagerly
looking forward to buying a ps4 I was
actually at the midnight release of the
ps4 but I didn't get my ps4 because I
didn't have quite enough of it paid off
yet and I thought I had so unfortunately
my pre-order a copy went to somebody
else
it sucked eventually I will get one so
don't think that I'm just some hater of
Sony or Microsoft I'm not I just want to
wait until there are some launch titles
I actually prefer to own and some of
these problems are ironed out so
according to Sony 0.4 percent of all
Playstations that were released to
consumers are broken like they're
literally broken they're just broken
people are starting to refer to them as
$400 bricks if you remember what
happened with the Xbox 360 the red ring
of death weight just broke and
broadcasts this little red ring ps4s are
showing this blue light and nothing else
and that's become referred to as the
blue light of death the same thing is
happening to Xbox one certain systems
are arriving to consumers and even press
people who review the systems and they
are just broken or covered in scuffs for
instance one of the Xbox ones that IGN
receive
to actually review cannot read discs one
of the systems they received to review
can't play blu-rays or games what the
hell man and as I was reading these
articles none of them are really
affecting me personally I hadn't known
someone or encountered someone
personally in real life who had some of
these problems
they were just things I heard on the
internet and that might have something
to do with the fact that the Wii U the
ps4 and the Xbox one are the first three
home consoles available after the rise
of social media because now everyone's
talking everywhere about these systems
and you're gonna hear a lot more things
about them being broken so nevertheless
I was like yeah it's probably not that
big of a deal however a friend of mine
the other day posted on his Twitter
another social media outlet that his ps4
literally broke and he is pressed for
video games
he received his to review free of charge
and it broke he's a good pal of mine
he's named Jake Baldino you may know him
from pretty much it he does movie
reviews and game reviews there but he
also has his own channel called because
of video games and he sent me a clip
explaining exactly what happened hey
Chris and hey everyone out there I'm
Jake and this is my playstation 4 and
unfortunately I have a perfect example
for what this video is about that was a
professional game reviewer I've been
lucky enough to have my playstation 4
for some time but just recently I had a
big issue happen with mine though this
drive doesn't work anymore I was in the
middle of playing a game and it
completely crashed and then the disc
drive ejected the disc randomly I've
never seen that before
and now the disk drive keeps spinning
the wrong way and won't take in any new
discs that's a big problem
I've also had a lot of weird crashes and
really weird instances of the system
randomly powering on and powering off
without me doing anything and well I'm
not totally jammed up about it it's fine
these things happen I can send it to
Sony and get a new one
the fact that I'm saying it's fine and
it happens shows a problem as
generations advance and games get more
and more exciting with innovations and
technological advancements and just
awesome stuff to do the trade-off is is
that things get a lot more complicated
such as with problems with my ps4 people
who had problems with Xbox 360s in the
red ring of light and it really boils
down to we can't blow in cartridges
anymore to fix everything
Wow what thank you Jake I appreciate
that you are awesome and I love you I
love you a lot now I feel the need to
reiterate again this is not a Sony or
Microsoft bashing party as I said I will
buy these systems eventually and I'm
looking forward to that once they iron
some of these details out and there are
actually some launch titles I want to
play like Metal Gear
SolidFire speaking of launch titles
where are they older systems that were
released in the 90s and 80s had great
titles to play as soon as you got them
now what do we have call of duty ghosts'
I mean it might be a fun game but really
I mean is that a must-own game no it's
not so I did some research these are
some of the launch titles that came with
previous systems that are fairly well
known the NES came with duck hunt
Excitebike and Super Mario Brothers the
Super NES came with Super Mario World
and f-zero n64 came with pilot wings 64
and Super Mario 64 the PlayStation 2 had
timesplitters Gamecube had Star Wars
Rogue leader in Luigi's Mansion xbox had
halo the we had Zelda Twilight Princess
these are games that I would want to
play instantly like as soon as you got
the system it's like yes I want to play
that game right now ps4 and Xbox one
don't have any those games where are
they it's like you've had years to
create these systems don't you think you
might want to release a game that gamers
are like I must instantly own that game
because most gamers are just like I must
instantly own the system that's what
they want they want to buy the system
right now as soon as possible then it
just kind of sits there and like what
I'm gonna do I guess I'll browse Netflix
and with all these systems arriving just
literally broken in the box it makes me
remember the fact that I have my
Nintendo 64 that I have had since 1997
and it still works perfectly there's
nothing wrong with it in fact let me
tell you guys a very interesting story
when I was in my mid-teens I had all my
Nintendo 64 games with me in the car I
had gone over to my friend's house we
had spent the night we had fun I brought
over my entire case at Nintendo 64 games
controllers memory cards everything my
parents pick me up the next morning they
brought me back to my house for whatever
reason I believe I had to tie my shoe
when I got out of the car I set all my
games on top of the car I tied my shoe I
went inside the next morning I was about
to play one of my games and I realized
oh crap they're outside still now it's
late fall okay there is frost and snow
all over the place so I immediately
think two things one someone stole my
games because they've been sitting on
that car forever or two they are broken
to crap so I go outside and believe it
or not my games were actually still
there on the roof and I grabbed him and
I was thinking crying I was like my
games they're all broken like there was
like 30 games in this box and they were
just they were shocked
there was frost on all
them some had ice on them some were
sticking together because of the ice it
was horrible I brought him inside I was
very very sad my dad come up to me and
said you know what son let's try
something he went in the bathroom he
came out with a hairdryer
we sat there for an hour hairdryer every
single one of these cartridges all of
the controllers and the memory cards
guess what they still worked and they
never broke ever they still work those
games sat outside in below freezing
weather literally froze it still worked
so am i saying that Nintendo is better
than Sony or Sony is better than
Microsoft no I'm not saying anything
like that this is not a biased video all
I'm saying is that I love my ps3 I use
it every day I literally do every single
day I use my ps3 whether it's Netflix or
games or swimming along those lines but
all this new technology is so fragile
it's like if you do the slightest thing
wrong with it it's all just gonna fall
apart also there's this new rise of
something called DLC or downloadable
content I think it sucks when I grew up
to get a whole bunch of extra content
you had to beat the game when I beat
Metal Gear Solid I got snakes bandana
and then I could do all these amazing
things and it was so cool nowadays I can
pop in that game that cost me $59.99
plus tax and they pay like another 30
bucks and maybe I can have some special
features of some kind it doesn't matter
if I beat the game it doesn't matter of
fact more Skills and other players which
gives me more things that other players
did not have I have to pay $30 to get it
it's annoying
what the hell is up with that now
obviously you guys may know that I am a
big Nintendo fan I have Nintendo power
magazines from back in the day I have so
many Wii games Gamecube and 64 NES Super
NES games I still do not have a Wii U
why is that there's no games where are
the games they literally just came out
with a game that I actually want Super
Mario World 3d Pikmin 3 I kind of do
want but just because you want one game
that you kind of want it's not like I'm
gonna drop the money on this system that
has this big control that looks like
Sega Game Gear in your hand
there's just something slightly wrong
with systems nowadays and I think I have
the ultimate solution for what it is and
I think I know exactly what it is gaming
systems used to be made for gamers now
they're made for consumers because if I
really think about it what do I use my
PlayStation 3 more for games or the fact
that I can stream Netflix through it
it's Netflix because it's not just a
game system I can
to do other things with it that's great
I actually really love that what I'm
saying is I think game developers need
to focus on games that's something that
Nintendo has always done that's one of
the reasons I've always loved Nintendo
because they do try to make great games
for players even if the Wii was filled
with endless needless child games party
games and all kinds of stuff
I think if Sony Microsoft and Nintendo
focused on the games focused on the
gamers then they will be successful so
what are you guys thoughts in all of
this the broken systems the launch
titles Nintendo Microsoft Sony all of
this I'd love to hear you guys below
sound off and let me once again remind
you I will be more than likely buying
all of these systems eventually this is
a rant more on the current state of
things as always guys thanks very much
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]